قال مساعد وزير الخارجيه الايرانيين
للشؤون السياسيه وكبير المفوضين النوويين
علي باقر ايه ان المفاوضات النوويه لا
تزال متواصله واضاف ان بلاده تطالب بضروره
رفع العقوبات الذي فرضها الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب والعراقيل التي
تمنعها من الاستفاده من المزايا
الاقتصاديه
للاتفاق النووي
المفاوضات وهذا المسار ولا يزال متواصلا
حتى اللحظه ولم يشهد انقطاع وايران تؤكد
مواقفها المنطقيه في المفاوضات وهي رفع
جميع العقوبات التي فرضها الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب وايقاف العراقيل التي
تمنع ايران من الاستفاده من جميع
الاقتصاديه لاتفاق النووي هذه اهداف
اساسيه بالنسبه لنا والمفاوضات تتواصل ضمن
هذا الاطار